montée d'angoissé mais les gens
continuaient leur place et on va réviser
la chanson mon dieu
un monde sépare là vous êtes en train de
rentrer dans leurs laptops nettement
encore sur scène ma chérie ça allait
rentrer dans le nanomètre j'entends les
applaudissements on en attend les gens
qui ont payé leurs places de concert les
îles agathe est ce que vous avez réalisé
l'ascension 2 à réviser quelques
chansons des vous avez rêvé quelques
chansons de véronique sanson amoureuse
hamon agathe vous allez rentrer sur soi
et vous irez vous désormais au sommet
agathe vous allez rentrer sur scène vous
voulez faire de la chanson vous voulez
vous reconvertir dans la chanson vous
allez rentrer sur ça mais vous avez
chanté l'adulte ou vous allez chanter
vous avez chanté amoureuse aux côtés de
véronique sanson d'accord agathe mettez
un malade ou quoi
elle avoue pouvoir mais la gamme
véronique sanson a été super elle nous a
dit oui tu es sûr qu'aller au courant
bah bien sûr que le court on va non pas
sur la scène de véronique sur son
cocktail crois qu'on va arriver à 30 il
vient chanter avec toi
l'atomisation drague at elle agace vous
allez faire le final avec véronique
chansons et d'amoureuse vous attend
égalise à l'essai dans un instant
j'espère que ça va être bon moment pour
vous agace
allez on y va si on fait à magath sur
scène amené à gap sur scène véronique va
démarrer la musique al ala ne redémarre
à pour unique sens ont déjà démarré
il faut lui dire qu'elle peut démarrer
un verrou dit comme ça le rang dans
l'est
il
rapporte le sauveur
je ne veux pas arriver le soleil
logiquement ces deux autres
in us
je ne te vois
6 m
c'est vrai
on vit
je
n'est plus
si on
je ne sais plus ici
je ressens l'appui d'autres planètes
tout notre place
quand tu perds tout contre lui
quand ce sens que j'entre dans sa vie
je prie pour que destin manceau
je prie pour elle est diablement pas
et l'angoissé me montre son visage
me sens safari sont là
ça
mes mains
ce goût sur le g2 san
m
je suis
non je suis loin
je n'ai pur
man toute ma tête
je ne suis plus d'ici
je
ici
je ressens l'appui une autre place
une autre paire au liban mais qu'est-ce
que vous avez quelque chose à dire
agathe n'est pas que je parle mais n'en
attendais parce que véronique sanson et
à côté de vous agathe vous avez super
bien chanter et 0,10 qu'est-ce qu'on
pouvait aller à côté d'un gâteau puisque
vous m'entendez verrou dit véronique
sanson et là je suis au près
je suis désolé comment va-t-on sortir de
la bouche agathoise et après je vais y
aller oui oui oui elle existe elle
pleure elle tremble pas plus être la
vraie
c'est qui
braga
papa
pado
m
avec des formes
b mais pas de but et bien donc je
m'appelle lui ce journal je chante jeudi
véronique sanson chantait divinement
bien vous êtes formidables merci google
yannick lucot coach vocal dana à tolérer
cela je sais franchement une droite a
fait un petit kiff
ah mais moi j'y croyais non mais t'as
faim tu actives quand même ah mais oui
messieurs je chiale aymaras j'étais en
panique c'était acceptable leur santé
franchement tu as bien chanter et la
vérité parce qu'au début je me suis fait
elle va le sentir et où mais là quand je
t'ai vu pleurer tout je me suis dit
c'est ta de la très bonne année vraiment
lola pas chérie